how's it going ladies and gentlemen my
name is matt you're watching code tech
tutorials and i just wanted to say thank
you for 4
000 subs we're a little past that now
but hey i'm just getting around to
making
this video life's uh been throwing me a
few curved balls so a little delayed on
the videos
recently so just fyi but
i do have something a little special and
fun for everybody today
turns out i've been saving up these
memes for this very special moment not
just any memes
coding memes and you're wondering where
my green screen went i just took it down
i got tired of it
it was it was annoying all right let's
let's check out some coding memes and
we're just gonna have a laugh have some
fun and i'm gonna comment on what i see
oh geez here we go all right i've got
this little folder
that i've just been saving memes in so
we're gonna we're gonna dig in
we're gonna go through all of them
all right here we go
uh my teammates appreciating me for
being available during the weekends
me an introverted duck who doesn't have
a social life
uh is that what it's like is that why
people work weekends because they don't
really have much else to do
sometimes it's just good money but not a
bad meme
all right see what else we got next
the next thing didn't work next there we
go
we look oh i say i gotta i gotta zoom
we'd like to cash our 1400 government
checks
look at us
get the government off my back more
freedomless
these aren't this isn't the coding i
guess this is just something that's
funny that i say
all right but yeah this is true you see
people like this whole time hating on
the government
then they are just cashing their checks
if you really hate the government don't
want anything from them
just send the check back okay or if
you're going to cash the check
take off your bumper stickers so you're
not a hypocrite
this is why is there a sniper rifle up
here
this guy would get pulled over so fast
anywhere in america
so fast all right next one
is four years a lot depends on the
context experience in c
plus programming no experience in python
or javascript yes
oh i can so relate i'm i'm still
struggling
yeah you guys probably know well some of
you i don't know depends how you came
across this video i guess
but if you've been here for a while you
know that i'm a c plus programmer
and i guess i'll share a little story
this is funny
because python do i have to should i
explain it i don't know
it's pretty obvious but i just want to
say that i can relate
i still don't feel that good at c plus
plus although
i seem to be i mean i'm pretty good not
bad
but i've been doing it for what like
five or six years and i still feel like
i'm a noob
a lot of times because i'll be like how
the heck do you do this there's so much
there's so many things you can do with
this language
so it's just so much and
the shortcuts in c plus plus
you basically have to build a library of
your own shortcuts because like there's
like these giant lines of code you have
to do to do one thing like you want to
cast an
integer do a character it's like a ton
of lines of code with python and
javascript it's just like
nothing you know you just do it so
just the memory specificness all right
let's go i'm beating this one
beating this one like a dead horse let's
go to the next one
i finally found it the world's funniest
color
boob 69 it's a pink color i love it
boob 69. i would have colored
all right me my declining mental health
another mechanical keyboard
you know mechanical keyboards do make me
happy they make me really happy
although i don't buy them like crazy
unlike magic cards only buy magic so
this should for me this should say
another magic card
that's what i do with all right but
let's move on
all right let's not talk about my mental
health alright it's already it's already
being destroyed enough by youtube all
right lack of lamb
lack of
memes to cure your day all right how dad
are you oh
yeah i can deal with this i'm a dad
all right guess it's free then when the
cashier has trouble scanning i am
have i ever done that i wonder how many
of these i could check i don't know if
i've ever done that
i don't think i have but i've heard
people have done it to me though because
i've worked
at a cashier before in my life doing
things and
uh i've definitely had people say that
to me
but i don't think i've ever done it
found it after
pointing a stud finder at your chest
i should do that but i don't think i
have all right looks like we'll have to
amputate
when a kid has a mushroom i'm going to
use this later today
whenever my kid gets injured later today
i don't know that's
he's not going to get in i don't know
why i set up like that all right let's
rock and roll
it's time to leave i do this all the
time except i say
i do say let's rock and roll but usually
i say let's make like a ball and roll
ah that's pretty it's pretty dad like
all right
did you fall in when the kid
uh we used to do this as siblings to
each other all the time
or more commonly we would say do you
need a log change
all right when someone makes mistakes
left for right no you're other right
yeah
done that one what's the damage before
looking at a bill yep done that one
can you do mine next when seeing a
neighbor washing their car
um don't think i have but that's not bad
i was just resting my eyes after falling
asleep on the couch
yeah guess
they'll let anyone in here when seeing a
friend
okay yeah i don't know if i've done that
one probably not
glad we're not going that way when
seeing traffic on the other side of the
road
yeah all the time i've drove in big
cities
where this is common all right can't get
very far without these after forgetting
your keys yep
little courses driving past work oh my
gosh
so hits home i do this every time look
horses
and everybody's like i don't care dad
see horses all the time all right
i'm not paying to heat the whole
neighborhood when the door is open
i usually have the reverse of this i'm
not paying to cool the whole
world or whatever the ac is on but same
thing
yeah it's not heavy just awkward
carrying something heavy i haven't done
that yet but
actually maybe i have i think i've said
this when uh carrying amps and stuff
when i used to be in bands
it's not heavy just awkward yeah not
quite those words but
yeah random story i had
a tube amp that had a handle on the top
it was like this rubber handle
i used to you know carry it by it and
one day when i was carrying this
expensive
two-band like into the venue or whatever
the this the handle broke it just
straight up snapped on me
oh man that was that was a rough day i
i didn't break the amp like i somehow
like wedged it up against my body
and leg like as it was falling
so luckily the dam didn't get damaged
but holy i remember that because
i had that moment of like my heart
sinking panic like i'm about to lose my
really expensive amp to a
a fall but luckily somehow i caught it
like on my leg
i don't even know but it hurts it hurt
me
i damaged myself to save my amp is that
not the sign
of a true musician
all right people don't know how to drive
in this town every town you're in
i think i'm that guy pretty sure i'm the
guy that people say that
now because well
i don't know once you have a lot of
hours on the road you know occasionally
you do something stupid
you miss a sign or you go the wrong way
it just happens
and i've been that guy and i'm pretty
sure that people looked at me like oh
god who was sketching how to drive but
whatever
let's let's move on we needed this rain
every time it rains
yep i say that pretty much every time
when someone complains about the rain
it's like we need rain
how else we gonna eat our vegetables
gonna grow how are you gonna grow we
need this ring
that's how they get you after declining
additional warranty protection
i've heard someone say that i don't
think i said that i usually just say no
thanks
but maybe maybe i'll try this one next
time that's how they get you
is that how they get you back already
how was it when someone comes back
inside because they forgot something
been there oh oh that's not going
anywhere
after tying something down yep i don't
know i think i
i don't i didn't get the exact count but
maybe some
one will in the video i'm pretty sure i
hit at least 50 percent of these so
i'm about 50 dad oh oh are there more
my scroll wheel like flips through this
so fast alright let's go to the next one
should christian families include santa
claus
ultimately the santa live will break
down trust between you and your child
but even more seriously do you believe
after five ten years of telling your
children to believe in and behave for a
man they can't see
they won't apply their broken trust
towards other man you told them to
believe in and behave for they can't see
jesus christ
in other words if you're lying to them
about santa
why should they believe you that you're
not lying to them about jesus
he's got a good point he's got a really
good point
oh and also so this is a bit of an
aside but it's related are you allowed
to do the santa live your christian
isn't it oh
okay behind my mouth my mouse feel good
all right
are you not allowed to lie when you're a
christian even to your kids or
are pranks okay there's a special clause
for
no pun intended uh
pranks i don't know i don't get it
never will never get this christianity
thing i know
some people really don't like that but
hey it doesn't make sense to me i can't
help that it doesn't make sense
maybe maybe they should make it make
more sense all right whatever let's move
on there's a 50 percent success
me what this is a weird sense all right
let's just let's read it me there is a
50
success 50 fail so if he does
surging twice it will be a hundred
percent success a hundred percent fail
so this makes you schrodinger's cat
this is okay i guess let's read the
comments because
obviously this makes no sense uh you're
not very good at math
there's there's combinatorics there
fifty percent
and another fifty percent don't make a
hundred percent it's somewhere around i
don't know
i'd have to do that but it's not a
hundred it's like
somewhere between seventy eight or
eighty or something like that not very
good about what is 50 plus 50
50 50. here you can see javascript
and it's natural
if you're a coder you'll get this
because that's what happens when you go
50
50 in javascript it literally adds them
together because they're all strings i
think
and not a big javascript programmer used
a little bit
all right let's move on birth control
effectiveness
condoms this looks like this looks like
a taco bell symbol all right 99
birth controls pills 99 learning to code
and assembly
uh i i get that this is funny and like
you know it's supposed to be
i think this is like not true at all
though because
if you can code an assembly you can make
a lot of money
and when you have a lot of money women
will see that and be like hey
security right there let's go for that
guy well that's all another thing but
the point is this meme actually doesn't
make sense learning the code and
assembly
will probably have the opposite effect
all right let's see that's just me being
a realist
you know i get it's just like you know
only nerds
simply nerds can't get girls or whatever
so it's not that funny because of that
but
for real simply coders make
bank they can get really good jobs and
they can make really cool youtube videos
that people actually watch
all right me slowly realizing that i
forgot to call
the function while yelling i think
uh i'm pretty sure i've done this in
every sin
every single stream um
look at this cat i love it pretty sure
oh
i wanted to zoom in not scroll okay
pretty sure i've done this
every time i've streamed coding which is
one of the reasons i kind of stopped
because it's so cringy it's always me
being like why doesn't this work
and then realizing that i just totally
did something wrong i'm like oh of
course it's not gonna work
i literally made it in a way so that it
wouldn't work and then got mad because
it wasn't
uh coding coding burns you out really
quick it's like a really
it's a really brain intensive thing you
can only like do it so long for me i've
started to figure out it's like two
hours two and a half hours before i'm
like i can't
i can't do this anymore i need to take a
break all right let's go to the next one
is there any more yeah bram milking
contest
competitors chrome eclipse android
studio
uh android studio craigslist
ram oh oh my gosh i love this this meme
is
does the android studio take more than
chrome i guess it depends what tabs you
have open
it's a good one though i love this cow's
face
continuous improvement is better than
delayed perfection
mark twain a little motivation for you
guys because that's not funny i just
for some reason drug it into my funnies
older
it's just motivation but this is this is
really important in coding because
coding is like
you can never get it perfect there's
always code that's going to be like you
look at later and be like i could have
done that better
so continues uh i don't know i'm trying
to relate it somewhere
there but it's a good point it's a good
point all right if you can't explain it
to a six-year-old
you don't understand yourself okay first
graders today we will learn
async await does anybody actually know
how to use async await
i guess i kind of do but i never
i don't know i'm not an expert in it
every time i have to use it i always
look it up and be like what is this
again one of those things with c plus
plus where it doesn't matter
how many years of experience you have
unless it's like 20 or 30
you still got to look stuff up all the
time just the way it is
at least for most of us all right code i
wrote to make it work
code i push to get yeah
dress it up uh
yeah i can sort of relate you know
i don't know if there's much to say
about this but
i feel like you don't have to like i
don't know it's it's good to pretty fire
code before
pushing it to get you know we're on your
formatter that sort of thing why not
all right what my neighbors see when i
emerge from my house once a week
oh geez you could literally just put my
face on that that would be accurate
all right let's see what else we got
that's it that's the end of them well
well well
well i just wanted to say once again
thank you guys for you know just
watching
and subbing and commenting and all that
stuff it really does mean a lot this has
been
quite an amazing experience just being
on youtube in general and doing this
sort of thing and i
i i got some big changes coming up
i don't want to spill all the beans in
this particular video
but some things i i'll make an
announcement i'll
say it all and do it all but some things
are going to be changing about the way i
do my content
online and i guess that's all i'm going
to say for the moment
really but i just want you to know that
i'm still working on things
changes are coming that's also one of
the reasons things are a little bit
delayed is because
on the back end of my life and all my
hobbies and stuff
i am reorganizing a few things
and i'll do an announcement video soon
on that all right well thank you guys
once again don't forget to smash all the
buttons and
that sort of thing i guess i just have
to say that it's like a requirement
making a youtube video these days
i'll see in the next one peace out take
care of yourselves keep coding
and slap a comment down below